>>Susan: Let's get started.
"Dear Super Duper Boys and Girls."
>>Narrator: It's the start of a super
day in Susan Corey's kindergarten class
at Fabian Elementary
School in Portland, Oregon.
>>Susan: Who is super
duper in this room?
>>All: I am!
>>Narrator: Across the hall fellow
kindergarten teacher Felipe is having
a different kind of morning.
>>Student: I want my mama!
>>Felipe: Oh you want your mama?
Why don't you get a Kleenex
so we can blow your nose?
Come on, let's go.
It's kind of like a magician.
You redirect, you know.
They're focused on one thing
and then you just get a Kleenex,
that was a redirection and then
they just need that little focus
to get back and then it's over.
>>Teacher: That's what
we're looking for.
To see what sound you're hearing.
Good job, yeah, yay.
>>Narrator: The subtle
magic of teaching
at Fabian has produced
remarkable results.
In a school where nearly
three-quarters
of the students receive free or
reduced lunch, ninety-seven percent
of the school's fifth graders
met or exceeded state standards
for both reading and math in 2005.
Most here would agree
that the key to achieving
such high standards is
to expect nothing less.
>>We all hold-
>>Very high expectations-
>>That they all can learn-
>>And we believe in them-
>>We teach them to set
goals for themselves.
>>And it's just understood here that
of course you're going to learn.
>>And they really do
rise to the occasion.
>>Kyleshia: Having expectation is a
good thing because you can actually-
is like setting your
goal and your benchmark.
>>Felipe: Let's find out
the 15, which in those 15?
>>Narrator: To help students achieve
their lofty goals teachers engage
parents as partners by visiting
their homes before the first day
of kindergarten.
>>Susan: We always make home
visits to meet the children
and kind of on their territory.
It makes them a little more
comfortable and it kind
of shows us a little
bit about their life.
>>Felipe: I think it makes them
not so scared of kindergarten
because they've already seen us.
They've already talked to us and that
helps us as well, the home visit.
>>Student: Thirteen,
fourteen, fifteen.
>>Narrator: Teachers also
work in grade-level teams.
>>TaKiyah: This is Monday right?
>>Narrator: Taquia Williams
and Meredith spend two hours each
week planning their first grade
lessons together.
>>Meredith: This will be good.
This is part of commun-
you know neighborhood.
If they have a library in their
neighborhood we can tie that in.
>>TaKiyah: Into it, yeah.
>>Meredith: Into that as well.
>>TaKiyah: I just love
working with my peers.
We are a unit and I can go back to
Susan or I can go back to Felipe
and I can go to Meredith anytime and
say "Hey, this is the situation here.
What can we do to solve it?"
And we all put a piece into it and
come up with some great examples
of what we need to do as a staff.
You know we reach out to each other.
>>Mary: I was thinking we should
go over all the little pieces
that we feel they kind
of have gaps with.
>>Narrator: Fourth
grade teachers Mary
and Gail Quigley take the
teamwork concept even further.
With the help of student teacher
Anna [Inaudible] they team teach 36
students in two shared classrooms.
>>Mary: For shared reading slash
writing we have you teaching a
grammar lesson.
>>Anna: Okay.
>>Mary: Do you want to
continue doing that?
>>Anna: Yeah, that's fine.
We're working through that book.
>>Mary: There's more to being
an educator than just teaching.
You have parents calling.
You have students who have questions.
Constant paperwork and so you always
have one teacher who can keep an eye
out while the other one is teaching.
And it really saves
time for us as well.
We can spend more time focusing on
the kids and focusing on the learning
than on did they turn
in their homework?
>>Narrator: Another key element
in Fabian's success is a
social-emotional learning curriculum
called Life Skills which is
taught at every grade level.
>>Mary: Everyone in here has
really been using the Life Skill
of initiative to try to
keep the floor picked up.
And to keep-
>>Moly: We are working really hard
on infusing in children the idea
of being a citizen, you know, a good
citizen of this school and this city
and state, and what it
means to be respectful.
What it means to give back.
What it means to be a good friend.
>>Mary: Who can help
these three people out?
>>Narrator: Fourth graders spend
20 minutes each day using the life
skills they've learned to
resolve everyday conflicts
like cutting into a game line.
>>Student: He could have said "Okay"
because the line goes by quick
when nobody argues and stuff.
>>Mary: We learned that, didn't we?
Using the life skill cooperation
we can play a lot faster, can't we?
>>Student: Yes.
>>Mary: Does anyone have
another piece of advice for them?
>>This gives us something
to talk about.
This gives us real moments.
There's programs out there that teach
the life skills in a different manner
but it's a canned program, meaning
you hold up a poster and you say
"This is Billy, this is Jenny.
They're fighting over a ball.
How can we help them?"
Whereas today there
were actual examples
of conflict and it applied to them.
>>You could have went
to another Four Square
and you could have walked
away from the situation.
>>That was a good one.
I like the walking away.
We have a lot of Four
Square games going don't we?
>>Narrator: The school's high
scores in English are the result
of an intense focus on
reading and writing skills.
>>Your story is going to be told
from the point of view of one
of these characters, and they're
going to explain what happened.
>>Narrator: And lessons in
the basics are often enhanced
by new technology tools.
>>Ladies and gentlemen, this
is where we're going to have
to use the life skill of
flexibility and patience,
because we need to
get into the server.
And here comes my inspiration
starter.
>>Part of teaching has
to do with entertaining.
You need to hook them.
You need to catch their attention.
>>Student: See?
"R".
>>Mary: And that's
what technology does.
It sucks them in.
It makes them interested
in their learning.
>>Okay, so I'm going
to look for a person.
>>Mary: I like that idea.
That's a good strategy.
>>Kyleshia: In the class we're
always usually calm and quiet
and we're not always chatter-bugs and
we usually listen to the teachers.
And the teachers really are
excellent teachers at their jobs
because they actually
they do learning
and at the same time
they do fun things.
>>Student: "Grandma
didn't have a change."
>>Narrator: Teachers aren't
the only ones who teach here.
Second graders regularly
read to kindergarteners.
>>According to my research
phytoplankton live in the part
of the ocean near the
surface that gets sunlight.
>>Narrator: Community volunteers
also come into the school
to spend time reading
with the students.
>>Two.
>>Two what?
>>Pears, but he was still hungry.
>>Susan: We read books
every day, sometimes two
and three times a day depending on
the children and they love stories.
>>Felipe: Point to it
if you see the squirrel.
>>Susan: I mean most
of the time a lot
of these kids have not heard stories
too often at home so they love this
and all I ask them to do is
to sit quietly and listen.
>>Felipe: A world far away inside my?
>>Student: Body!
>>Felipe: "Head" because
he's using her imagination.
>>Student: Imagination!
>>Felipe: Oh I like the way
Monte said "imagination".
>>Narrator: In the end, Fabian's
phenomenal success is the product
of dedicated teachers
working together
to realize the potential
they see in every child.
>>Meredith: And tell
me one thing about it.
>>TaKiyah: We have kids' lives in our
hands that we are responsible for.
And no matter what's happening the
ultimate goal that we set up is
that we have to make sure that we
are giving each kid an opportunity
to be successful.
>>And what about these two?
>>Student: Six.
>>TaKiyah: What about these two?
>>Student: Seven, eight.
>>Susan: Maybe we haven't
done it right the first time,
we think oh they'll learn
this way and they don't,
but if we try another
method it clicks.
>>Oh you guys are so smart!
>>Molly: It's about having faith
for one thing in the potential
of these children and then
not only having the faith
but then doing something with it.
We believe children can learn.
We believe they walk through our door
and we can take them,
you know, to the moon.
But it's using good assessment,
good strategies to make sure
that happens for all children.
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org